on vous en parle depuis ce matin québec
qui devrait qui compte installer des
caméras dans chacune des chambres des
nouvelles maisons pour aînés c'est ce
que l'on peut constater quand on
consulte un appel d'offres qui a été
fait par le ministère de la santé ça
soulève des questions de respect de la
vie privée on attend également plus de
réponses sur la manière dont elles
seront utilisées par le bruit d'un
président du conseil pour la protection
des malades est là pour nous en parler
bonjour monsieur brunet bonjour monsieur
une caméra comme ça dans ces nouvelles
chambres mon emprisonnement quand le
gouvernement veut nous dit c'est à des
fins préventives
on veut s'assurer que et arrivera pas
d'accident qu'on va être leur rapidement
une bonne ou une mauvaise idée
en fait le premier jour je veux dire
c'est que le gouvernement ça soit avec
nous à tous les mois et personne ne nous
a parlé de ça je trouve ça un peu
insultant qu'on nous consulte sur toutes
sortes de choses mais pas là-dessus tous
un peu bête
la deuxième commun qu'ils soumettraient
des caméras sur personne pour garder
écran souvenons nous le drame de la mère
de monsieur 17 ou le rapport du coroner
a signalé que les gens avaient vu sur
l'écran après coup madame sortir de
l'immeuble mais personne n'était au
poste pour voir l'écran ça prend du
personnel pour vérifier surveiller les
écrans sinon ce d'un large d'infos
d'accord une fausse
info sécurité bon mais pour pour les
faits d'intimité également bon vous êtes
avocat de formation si je ne m'abuse là
ça aussi ça pose certaines questions
parce qu'ils sont pas tous une malade
les gens qui sont dans ces résidences
l'a donné raison et les gens ont le
droit de refuser c'est la première chose
la deuxième c'est que déjà des caméras
on a déjà passé devant ce débat là quand
le gouvernement finalement autorisé les
caméras dans les jambes nous on avait
des réserves ont pensé à ce moment là
que la limite travail en amont avoir du
personnel mieux formés mieux avisés des
droits des usagers et gens plus
compétents pour tenter certains mais bon
finalement on est avec les caméras qui
je dois bien avouer ont servi à prouver
dès des drames qui sont survenus et des
exagérations dans la baisse des soins
cela dit au flore aussi de partager
cette caméra là son travail quelqu'un
qui vaut surveiller les écrans sinon je
le répète ça vous revient c'est un
leurre et puis la caméra acquis que la
famille installée par ailleurs bon mais
justement je voulais vous entendre là
dessus parce que des familles qui vont
dire oui mais doit-on voulait prévenir
la maltraitance on voulait prévenir du
vol on a installé une caméra alors vous
vous êtes pressés que la femme est
peut-être regarde la caméra la maison
mais y'a personne dans la dans la
résidence lucky qui sera là ou encore
alliés des effectifs qui devront le
faire
c'est souvent et malheureusement le
corps c'est des lancements de projets
qui peuvent être intéressants qui sont
pas discuté avec personne sur le terrain
du copo de nous et qui vont connaître ce
thème dans certaines dérives si on cap
attention mais surtout ne sont pas
utiles six personnes ont regardé écrire
ça prend du monde va rire des écrins où
sera le personnel on est déjà débordé on
est déjà rareté leur prendre quelqu'un
pour surveiller écran parce que dit on
ça va être plus sécuritaire les excuser
moi je crois qu est ce que tu as eu des
plaintes des patients ou des familles
qui se sont plaints parce qu'avec la
présence ils se sentaient surveillée où
on voulait qu'ils soient surveillés
est-ce que ce dossier le ccc d'actualité
alors les caméras sont installées
présentement par les familles avec leur
accord ouais c'est d'abord une caméra
lensois c'est pas mal réglés comme des
bas il ya du personnel qui qui certaines
difficultés notamment du supersonique du
mois je comptais y ait des caméras parce
que ça vous pouvez toutefois moins et
que moi je serai bien mon travail a
toujours l'envers de la médaille
la madame ont fait en sorte pour vous
touchez si c'est pas nécessaire parce
que des caméras qui nous surveillent zh
si on a de tout et je pense le gros bon
sens l'a emporté dans l'histoire des
caméras présentement tout cas jacques
est un cas et nous sommes ici en
présence d'un calme sans qu'un juge que
dix a déjà alors ouais il faudra voir
pour la suite des choses merci beaucoup
monsieur venaient
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
[Musique]